I'm in Paris right and my girl's not in
Paris and I'm like yo I'm gonna go to
the [__] Hermes store see if I can
get you a bag so we go in get sent into
a separate room the guy introduces
himself right his name is Adolf that's
his name now he got a Spanish accent I
go where you from man he goes Argentina
oh so I go oh like Adolfo he goes no
actually it's I go isn't it don't fall
in Spanish she goes yeah but my family
is German and I found him bro I found
him so Dove is trying to make sure we
get the best scenario with the bag once
the word Adolf was said bro melt it
tries to intervene he hasn't said
anything because he's just in a [__]
State of Shock Dove goes oh and by the
way um Adolf stops him right he just
goes nine we can figure out the
appointment for you on a different day
now Dove is like oh no I wasn't really
trying to do it and the guy just goes ah
we don't talk about this I go downstairs
another victory for Adolf over the Jews